[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii one of the most musically and
ethnographically compelling testimonies
in the fortune of video archive
is the one given by jack m a native of
the polish town
of shidwaviads jack had an impressive
memory
and was a great storyteller and singer
it is not worthy that jack was also
recorded for the folk song project
carried out in the 1980s jack remembered
really a wealth of the pre-war
traditional jewish repertoire
including batonis wedding jesters
recitatives
folk songs of all kinds songs in polish
some of which he learned while serving
in the army
one of the most mesmerizing either songs
jack sang on his testimony was
tribe de valesti fertig drive your waves
deep river
it is a song performed on behalf of a
woman who is longing for a beloved on
the bank of a deep river
and she asks the river to tell him about
her bitter faith
this is a pagan slavic trait which is
also referred to as folk judaism
superstitions and dialogue with the
forces of nature and other borrowings
from the para religious beliefs
of the slavic baltic finnic moldavian
and romanian neighbors
took their firm place in the jewish
folklore which shouldn't come as
surprise
given the 650 year long history of
coexistence
and this song is not an exception the
melody is typical for the eastern slavic
rural lyrical song of the 19th century
with its characteristic intrasyllabic
vocalization
and wide vocal range
she is she's singing like
she was standing by the ocean to the
waves
to instead of a letter she
those two i remember
but that was a third one but i can't
remember
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
jack m recalls that he learned some of
the songs he knows
from hoisingeth
courtyard and street singers who would
come from warsaw
to his town and sing the latest hits
but he learned this particular song from
the bala boste
the female boss in a shop where he was
apprenticing as a tailor
she would sing songs as she was working
including lullabies in his testimony
jack compares this song to a letter
addressed
to a lover who has gone away
he remembers two verses of what must
have been a longer ballad
comparable to the well-known papillis
d'orvice
or dunden
similar to other yiddish fluff songs in
the style of this european genre
reminiscent of the russian and german
folk repertoires
the renowned folklorist ruth rubin
wrote in her 1973 books book
voices of a people that i quote
an examination of 19th century yiddish
love songs
will reveal many parallels with old
german love songs of several centuries
ago
while other con authors contain only
fragmentary evidence of this early
ancestry
the bulk of yiddish folk songs today
however relate mainly to 19th century
life of the jews in the
terrorist pale of settlement
within this framework these love songs
were the forerunners
which inspired the first generations of
yiddish lyric poets
in modern yiddish literature and of
course
as the coordinator of the ruth rubin
legacy website
i have heard many such songs
that you can also now access easily as
since close to 2 000 songs have been
digitized and are now online as part of
this
project it is notable
that this type of songs was often
transmitted
through women who um
although they were not allowed to
perform uh publicly
mostly because of religious reasons
would sing abundantly
in their homes and like in the case of
jax balaboste at work
the emotions of the songs
are conveyed through images of nature
and tribe
the mountains and valleys represent
the greetings that the singer wishes to
send to their last love
at the same time they symbolize the very
distance
separating the singer from their loved
ones
while the ways can be seen as reflecting
the agitated emotional state caused
by their heartbreak and longing
as the joke goes if you find yourself
in a yiddish love song stay away from
the river
the same could be said of other european
folk songs
where desperate lovers sometimes end up
drowning themselves
although this song doesn't present such
a tragic
ending the topography of the feelings
in the last two lines convey bitterness
through the idea of depth whether it is
the valley
the river or the image of darkness
in their arrangement of this song the
thistle sleepovich ensemble
and sasha lurie have created a texture
with drone-like accompaniment in unison
in the melody which emphasizes both
the lyricism of the text
and the underlying darkness expressed
within
it's a beautiful work